natalie burnell is the host of the coin
stories podcast she joins us tonight to
answer those questions now thanks so
much for coming on so people are
watching this some people feel
vindicated others feel really worried
what do you make of it
hi tucker well thank you so much for
having me look we're seeing a sell-off
across the board it feels like no one is
safe right now and i know that can be
really scary for people but at the same
time we shouldn't really be surprised
because there's been so much excess
added to the system you mentioned it
earlier in the newscast i mean the
federal government has been printing
trillions of dollars in the last few
years they were printing before but it
was accelerated as the result of the
pandemic and that money had to flow
somewhere it went into stocks it went
into crypto and bitcoin and it caused
inflation now the government is trying
to take inflation seriously they have to
try to reduce the balance sheet they
have to try to raise interest rates to
make it more expensive to borrow in
record debt levels and so people are
selling assets they're selling stocks
some of those stocks going down further
than bitcoin people are selling bitcoin
and crypto and i want to make an
important distinction here because
bitcoin is not crypto bitcoin is digital
property whereas bitcoin is largely an
unregulated securities market and it's
similar in some ways to the dot-com
bubble of the 90s where you saw things
shoot up in value and then crash down
never to be heard from again and i urge
people caution because we saw some of
those stories in the last week whereas
bitcoin is a very young but quickly
growing technology network that has the
power to disrupt and revolutionize our
financial system and it was really
designed to decouple money from power
which has caused so many of the problems
that exist in society it is growing very
very quickly and i think we might see
some more short-term pain but in the
long run i think it's going to be a
winner
so it does and i think that's a really
nice explanation the way you describe
bitcoin
but the idea was that it would be
decoupled from fluctuations in the
equities market but it seems correlated
with the equities market do you expect
that to change over time
i do expect that to change and look
right now bitcoin has largely existed in
a qe environment where the government is
printing money it has been the
beneficiary of that so it does come down
but you know what in previous john downs
it's come down even further the 80 90
range we are not there yet could we see
it absolutely again this is a very young
very volatile early technology network
that's growing very quickly a lot of
people don't understand it yet but again
very different from the larger crypto
market bitcoin is a digital property
that has the potential to be in the
hands of eight billion people across the
world and give them access to a more
inclusive financial system and i think
it's important to remember that because
as you mentioned in the show with all
this money printing we've created a
system of debt that has crushed savers
and it's benefited the people at the top
it's socialized losses and privatized
gains and now we have a country that's
polarized and frustrated because people
feel left behind
yes i'm so nicely put um i'm glad you
came on tonight thank you very much good
to see you thank you for having me
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight